>>> RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR
PUTIN IS ATTACKING HIS O
PEOPLE.
LISTENO WHAT HE SAID TODAY
ABOUT RUSSIANS WHO DARE TO
SYMPATHIZE WITH UKRAINE OR THE
WEST.
>> Translator: THEY WILL TRY TO
BET ON THE SO-CALLED FIFTH
COLUMN ON TRAITORS ON THOSE WHO
EARN THEIR MONEY HERE BUT LIVE
OVER THERE.
LIVE NOT IN THE GEOGRAPHICAL
SENSE BUT IN THE WAY THEY THINK
WITH THE MIND SET OF A SLAVE.
THESE PEOPLE CANNOT LIVE WITHOUT
OYSTERS AND GENDER FREEDOM.
>> JOINING US NOW FORMER
UNDERCOVER KGB AGENT JACK.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
THE WORDS FROM PUTIN TODAY, I
FOUND SOME OF THEM FRANKLY
TERRIFYING.
HE DISCUSSED THE NECESSITY OF A
NATURAL SELF-CLEANSING OF
SOCIETY.
HE DESCRIBED PEOPLE WHO DARE TO
OPPOSE HIM AS FLIES TO BE SPIT
OUT.
TELL US WHAT THAT MEANS IN YOUR
VIEW.
ECHOES OF --
>> YOU KNOW WHO HE WAS
ATTACKING, THOUGH?
HE WASN'T ATTACKING ORDINARY
PEOPLE.
HE'S ATTACKING SOME OLIGARCHS,
THE ONES THAT LIVE MOSTLY IN
LONDON AND, YOU KNOW, HE'S
TICKED OFF AT THEM BECAUSE THEY
USED TO BE IN HIS CAMP AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN, BECAUSE OF THEIR
LIFESTYLE BEING THREATENED, THEY
ARE, YOU KNOW, SORT OF LEAVING
HIM AND AS ONE OF THE OLIGARCHS
PUT A PREMIUM ON HIS -- ON
VLADIMIR'S HEAD, THAT REALLY GOT
HIM TICKED OFF.
REMEMBER IN THE PAST WHEN HE
FIRST GOT TO POWER THERE WAS
SOME OLIGARCHS THAT DIDN'T PLAY
WITH HIM.
HE PUT THEM IN JAIL.
>> YEAH.
ARE YOU WORRIED THAT PUTIN AS
HIS INVASION FORCE SLOWS, MEETS
OBSTACLES, LOSES PERSONNEL BY
THE THOUSANDS, THAT HE BECOMES
MORE, NOT LESS RUTHLESS?
>> THAT IS INDEED HIS HISTORY.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE ONE COMMENT.
WE SHOULD NOT WILLY-NILLY DRAW
RED LINES BECAUSE IT'S HAPPENED
IN AMERICAN HISTORY WE DREW A
RED LINE IN SYRIA.
YOU LOSE CREDIBILITY.
WE HAVE TO BE REALLY CAREFUL
BECAUSE IN ESCALATION OF THIS
CONFLICT, THERE IS SOMETHING
THAT I THINK ABOUT WITH UP
HORNS.
>> WELL, YOU'RE RIGHT TO SITE
THE DANGERS THERE.
AS YOU KNOW, PUTIN HAS SOME
ENEMIES AT HOME.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THERE COULD
BE ANY SERIOUS INTERNAL
OPPOSITION?
AN UNSUCCESSFUL COUP IN 1991,
DOES PUTIN FACE SUCH A RISK AT
HOME TODAY?
>> YES, BUT NOT FROM HIS INNER
CIRCLE.
HE HAS HIS OLD BUDDIES THAT FROM
THE KGB, YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY BUT MAYBE 40, 50.
THEIR DESTINY IS ATTACHED TO
HIS.
SO THEY'RE NOT GOING TO MOVE.
HOWEVER, THERE ARE OTHER POWER
PLAYERS PARTICULARLY THE ARMY,
THE MILITARY AND PERHAPS
SOMEBODY IN THE INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES WHO ARE NOT AS BEHOLDED
TO VLADIMIR AND, YOU KNOW, ONE
WOULD THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
GENERALS WHO ARE JUST LIKE JUST,
YOU KNOW, RAW MILITARY PEOPLE
WHO EVENTUALLY WILL NOT DO WHAT
HE WANTS THEM TO DO IN TERMS OF
COMMITTING MORE ATROCITIES.
THAT'S A DANGER TO VLADIMIR
PUTIN, FOR SURE.
>> PARTICULARLY AS T